[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je n'aime pas faire les choses seuls
seul cette année j'aurai accompli
beaucoup moins de choses par exemple je
n'aurais pas fait de rugby je n'aurais
pas couru non plus les deux semi
marathon je n'aurais pas non plus
effectué le raid hannibal pour que ceux
qui connaissent la dynamique de groupe
me tire vraiment vers le haut à chacun
son dada certains préféreront faire des
sudokus lui d'autres jouer à la pelote
moi ce que j'aime c'est me dépasser
lorsque j'ai ai appris le thème du tedx
la première image qui m'est venu à
l'esprit c'est celle là
alors certains y verront un océan
tumultueux la crainte d'aller naviguer
dessus moi dans cette photo je vois de
superbes conditions de navigation j'y
vois un défi l'envi traverser cet océan
et d'aller voir ce qui se passe à
l'horizon cette photographie gelé prise
il ya un an lorsque j'ai réalisé la
traversée du canada jusqu'aux caraïbes à
la voile dix jours non-stop de
navigation nous étions 10 à bord j'étais
la seule femme la plus jeune et j'ai un
ami qui a embarqué avec nous louis alors
qu'il n'avait quasiment jamais fait de
voile auparavant vous vous rendez compte
et il a eu le mal de mer et il ya eu une
nuit où on a rencontré des conditions de
voile très difficile beaucoup de vent la
voile d'avant s'est déchiré on a dû tout
sortir sur le pont pour essayer de
réparer tout cela et malgré ces
difficultés nous sommes tous arrivés à
bon port ensemble je crois à la
dynamique de groupe
et en les capacités infinies d'un groupe
à se dépasser ensemble grâce à ses
expériences dans un groupe il n'y a pas
que l'entr'aide il n'y a pas que
l'esprit de compétition il n'ya pas que
les rivalités un groupe et surtout une
source d'inspiration
c'est en travaillant en groupes que vous
allez avoir des problèmes que vous allez
avoir des réussites et que vous allez
apprendre à vous connaître
du moins moi j'ai construit ma
personnalité grâce au dynamique de
groupe
qu'est ce qui fait que j'ai envie de me
dépasser
qu'est ce qui fait que j'arrive à me
ce sont les dynamiques de groupe
réellement quatre mois auparavant avant
cette traversée en juillet 2016 j'ai
réalisé une autre régate sur ce même
voiliers plus courte cette fois c'était
seulement 48 heures nous étions c'est
d'abord à nouveau j'étais la seule femme
à bord la plus jeune
sauf que là la différence c'est que les
autres membres de l'équipage étaient
tous mes directeurs et le pdg de
l'entreprise pour laquelle j'étais en
stage et nous partons il pleut nous
sommes trompés
il fait froid il ya du vent mais au
moins nous avançons bien sûr notre
bateau
la nuit tombe et nous décidons de passer
la nuit au rappel alors c'est à dire que
votre bateau penche comme ça vous vous
asseyez sur la coque les jambes dans le
vide et en fait vous servez de
contrepoids pour que le bateau avance
plus vite la pluie le froid
je ne me suis jamais senti aussi faible
physiquement et ce n'est pas peu dire
malgré cela j'ai tenu jusqu'au lever du
jour pourquoi parce que j'ai senti qu'à
tout cas côté de moi il y avait mes deux
compagnons qui eux aussi tenait il
n'était pas mieux comment il avait le
mal de mer mais aussi rester sur place
et c'est vraiment cette dynamique de
groupe
qui a fait que moi j'ai tenu jusqu'à la
fin jusqu'au lever du jour que j'ai vu
le lever du soleil et que j'ai dépassé
et j'ai repoussé mes limites
il ya deux choses qui sont importantes
pour moi la première chose c'est la
confiance
avoir confiance en soi ce n'est pas
facile mais il faut avoir confiance en
le groupe avec lequel on travaille
la deuxième chose c'est le focus positif
il ya une citation de mark twain que
j'aime beaucoup et qui dit il ne savait
pas que c'était impossible alors ils
l'ont fait cette citation est génial
cela ne sert à rien de de s'imposer des
limites de d'appréhender les situations
avec un côté négatif de se dire de toute
façon sera impossible tant pis on n'y va
pas on le fait pas non ça sert à rien au
contraire il faut appréhender des
situations de façon positive
croire en son potentiel personnel croire
en les capacités du groupe avec lequel
on travaille et avec qui on va mener les
choses faire ce projet est peut-être que
ça me semble compliqué au début mais
peut-être que finalement on va y arriver
ensemble
vous ne vous imaginez pas à quel point
la manière dont vous choisissez de dire
les choses a un impact sur les personnes
qui vous entourent la manière dont vous
jouissez de dire les choses de façon
négative ou positive
par exemple au rugby je veux très bien
choisir d'être négative ou positive
les filles j'en peux plus là vraiment
c'est le 20ème squad qu'on fait là j'en
peux plus je vais arrêter je suis
incapable de continuer là j'en peux plus
ok les filles c'est de récompenser dia
mais les filles il faut qu'on pense au
goûter qu'on a après la allez les filles
c'est pas facile mais ça nous fait du
fort les filles et allez on continue
jusqu'au bout alors je fais je m'amuse
sur scène mais vous comprenez bien à
quel point la la façon dont j'ai dit les
choses du tout avoir le même résultat
la première façon négative elle est
joueuse autour de moi vont se dire aux
gens un peu plus loin non plus tant pis
on arrête on va pas jusqu'au bout alors
que la deuxième façon de le dire de
baumanière beaucoup plus positive les
filles autour de moi font se dire ok
elle a raison à nous embête mais à la
raison on est capable de le faire ça
nous fait du bien alors on continue
ensemble jusqu'au bout
et cet état d'esprit positif et très
important comment est ce que j'arrive à
me dépasser
j'essaye d'avoir confiance en moi c'est
pas facile mais j'essaye je fais
confiance en le groupe avec lequel je
travaille et surtout je garde ce focus
positif alors je parle beaucoup de sport
parce que c' est certes je l'appliqué en
sport et que c'est ma passion mais je me
suis rendu compte que l'appliquer de
manière quotidienne
ce focus positif il fait énormément de
bien cela attire notamment les bonnes
personnes autour de moi dans la société
aujourd'hui beaucoup d'informations
négatives sont répandus et finalement il
ya très peu de soutien positive faire
des compliments félicité partager autour
de nous tous ces efforts que l'on fait
au quotidien et qui nous demandent
quelque chose et qui nous apporte
beaucoup finalement alors je vous invite
à tous aujourd'hui de garder cette étape
esprit positif quel est le compliment
que vous allez faire aujourd'hui en
sortant de la salle ou demain et pour
les plus motivés d'entre vous quel est
le prochain domaine dans lequel vous
avez envie de dépasser alors choisissez
de voir dans cette photographie non pas
un océan qui vous inspire la crainte non
pas ne vous dit pas je ne serais jamais
capable de le traverser au contraire
garder cet état d'esprit positif et
dites vous oui moi aussi je suis
peut-être capable de le traverser et
avec mon groupe nous sommes peut être
capable de le traverser ensemble
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]